thanks for coming oh thanks for having
me yeah very cool to meet you
um first there's a lot to talk about
first of all uh
golf has become such a such a big sport
in the last 10 years it's been
so huge your approach to the game is
completely opposite any other
professional golfer's approach it seems
to me
and and completely different as an
athlete you're completely different from
most athletes
you hate exercise you despise health
food
you smoke you drink and it works for you
is that right if we had cards i'd use
them too man i'll tell you what we could
use them but
i don't know i love it i love my life
yeah yeah well i can see why
you've been you've said that working at
you think that if you worked out it
would hurt your golf game
now now most other golfers now they've
it's almost a scientific approach
they're working out every single muscle
group you've said you don't want to do
that it would be bad for your game why
well i figure i'm not going to run cause
i we walk seven miles a day
so the running's out but right i think a
lot of times guys are getting too bulky
in here
you know which you don't have that
problem
which is good you could be a good golfer
um i've done it intentionally for my
golf game exactly
i uh i want that flexibility which is
why i yeah i have absolutely there's no
muscle groups in here i've had them
removed right
i carry this in case it gets windy it's
not going to blow me over
so it gives you some ballast so you
refuse to work
out now as i said golf has become such a
scientific game
people are isolating they're they're
watching uh you know slow down footage
of their
swing they're hiring special gurus and
coaches to analyze
sort of every you know particle of their
game you have a simple motto this is a
quote
i just hit it as hard as i can and if i
can find it i hit it again
you roll up it and then you go looking
for it
it's super terms i just grip it and rip
it basically grip it and rip it
and and it really does just go and are
you when you hit it well or
are you as surprised as anybody i mean
do you do you get in a zone first you
just you just
hit this ball as hard as you can and
then okay let's go see if i can find it
just depends how
how hung over i am i let my caddy look
for that okay the caddy
all right well let's talk about
let's talk about some things your past
sponsors you know
we know that they're everyone's trying
to get nike or adidas or you know some
some sponsor like that your past
sponsors have been a little unusual
dunkin donuts one day one day you were
sponsored one day for dunkin donuts
battle of the bridges uh
well i've been this 0-4 i've been all
for us playing with tiger
hank keaney and phil mickelson okay and
um
it's funny we get done and after you get
done we got our butts beat but
i was playing with phil and hank and
tiger beating him but
uh we get in there's a big tent where we
got to talk to the sponsors and all the
there's about you know 2
000 people tiger gets up and he says
yeah that's really cool jd
dunkin donuts and trim spawns that's
right you you know
hey tiger you know it's better than a a
and miller lite
so on the same day that you had dunkin
donuts you also were promoting trim spa
at the same time exactly
and hooters hooters was a sponsor is
that right
no questions there i'd wear that shirt
yeah
you don't believe there should you don't
like a dress code in golf that you find
that offensively no i mean i
i feel like somebody's got a thumb in my
throat when i wear one of them things
i really do it's called a tie is that
what it is
this newfangled thing called the tie
yeah looks like i'm overdressed again
yeah yeah this is nice i like the
jewelry my blue bling bling
yeah but you're comfortable you're
comfortable in that but a tie would
freak you out
exactly um what about but most golf
courses
uh require that you're you know that you
wear a certain
you know standard of clothing yeah no i
hate it you hate it yeah
you have your own golf course that you
bought is there is there a dress code
there yeah if you wear a tie you're
kicked out
yeah if you wear slacks you're kicked
out right
basically all you gotta do is cover your
private parts and you can play my golf
course
you have a tricked-out golf cart i
understand you you know you have a
special golf cart that you have made to
your specifications what's
everybody that you know back here all
your people and they said it will outrun
the tourists that you drive
i have a 91 ford taurus i will race your
golf cart any day
yeah yeah not just the regular ford
taurus but the ford taurus show
oh beautiful the one the ladies go for
how many batteries does that have three
c batteries yeah yeah i've got i got
eight and it'll do about 50 miles an
hour
50 your golf cart will go 50 miles an
hour it's called a humdinger
a hum dinger yeah all right so it's got
a giant it must be all
engine this thing it's got eight
batteries and it pretty much is yeah
do you ever go 50 miles an hour on the
golf course oh yeah it's fun
yeah like i said i like to promote you
know fast play
right right so you just move it right
along you don't even get out of the
thing you just it's like
yeah it's polo as far as your concern
i'm coming through